Hello and welcome to another Cambridge installation of toxic Google,
a Ted like to welcome professor Sarah Seager,
who's an astrophysicist and planetary scientists at Mit.
Her research focuses on theory,
computation data analysis of exoplanets.
Her research has introduced many new ideas to the field of exoplanet
characterization,
including work that led to the first detection of an exoplanet atmosphere.
Professor Seeger also works in the space instrumentation and space missions for
exoplanets,
including cube sats as a coinvestigator on the MIT lead tests,
a NASA explorer mission to be launched in 2017 and chair the NASA science and
technology definition team for a probe class star shade and telescope system for
direct imaging,
discovery and characterization of earth analogs.
And for that I'd like to welcome professor Seeger.
Thank you.
Okay,
thank you.
Well good afternoon and thanks for coming out to my talk.
The book is called Aliens.
I've called my talk something else and sometimes I like to call my talk the real
search for alien life.
So at the outset,
I want to say,
I'm not looking for like little green aliens coming here or I don't know if
anyone here believes in aliens.
But the funny thing is every time a new planet is in the news and people like me
get emails and phone calls,
I actually got this,
the most recent one.
Have any of you heard of the Trappist planets?
About a month ago?
There were these seven planets all or being a very cold star.
We'll talk about those in the bed and I just,
I don't pick up my phone because,
you know,
typically there are these calls about Ufo shows and things,
but this one was this lady who was very serious and very nice.
I just wanted to,
but you know,
she's been to this planet and would someone please talk to her about it?
And she was not really worked up or anything,
but it's incredible how the,
um,
you know,
the whole fiction of aliens and the movie's really,
uh,
is now coming to reality.
Actually.
Not that we're going to find them again,
but we were taking a very traditional scientific approach.
And so I'm here today to share with you just some of these approaches and I'm
right over at MIT and there's an awful lot of work going on there in this field.
So I'm going to walk you through what an exoplanet is,
where we're at,
and then I was going to tell you a bit about space telescope called Kepler and
the data that it has and how we use that data.
I'm going to funnel through towards how we think we're going to find signs of
life and we're all really excited about it in exoplanets.
I hope it won't be disappointing to you and when you realize what will
constitute,
not evidence,
but suggestion of the fact that there might be life out there for the future
when we get there.
But to start with,
I just have a few simple images and videos to let you know where we're at in
exoplanets.
And I have a movie clip made from this eyes on exoplanet software.
Um,
I do encourage you to download this and fool around with it.
And if you have,
um,
friends were interested or children or anyone like that,
it's really fun.
So this is just a video clip showing you a fake image of what we think our milky
way galaxy looks like.
But it quickly zooms into a real map of the sky.
And each of these highlighted objects is a star with known planets.
Um,
it's showing you some of the planets in our solar system.
If you look closely,
it will show you a spacecraft orbiting our son.
Keppler space craft is actually orbiting in our son,
not orbiting our earth.
And if you could zoom into part of earth and here it will click on the west
coast of North America and showing you what our spring night sky looks like.
And actually what it's showing you is all the white points are stars and all the
highlighted ones are stars with known planets.
There are thousands of stars out there that we know have planets orbiting them.
And we call those exoplanets.
Now,
you couldn't see all these stars with your naked eye.
You'd probably need by Nok yellers or a telescope to see them and then you
wouldn't see the planet or anything.
Um,
and here it's showing you these constellations overlaid and what it will do is
take us to a very special patch of the sky with thousands of stars with planets.
Does anyone know what that patch of sky is?
It's actually where a space telescope called Kepler,
um,
stared at that part of the sky for four years looking for planets.
I'll get to that in a minute.
In the software,
you can also type in a name of a star if you happen to know one that has a
planet and it will actually zoom into that part of the sky and show you,
um,
a schematic of the planets orbiting that star.
And look at this one has five planets orbiting the star and those are the
relative spacing of the orbits.
And you can click on this little menu here and here it's showing you a zone
around the star that a planet as heated by this star might be not too hot,
not too cold,
but just right for life.
Now here is where it has fine print,
which I think is designed so you can't read it,
but it says hypothetical visualization of planet because here we get to a point,
we don't have any data on planets like this except those in our own solar
system.
But there you go.
So you can actually use this and explore and you can click on any of these
objects and see what they are.
But my purpose was just to convey to you that there are,
you know,
in our night sky,
thousands of stars.
Our galaxy has billions of stars and we think there are hundreds of billions of
galaxies.
And so,
wow.
I mean there are planets out there,
there have to be aliens out there somewhere.
And here I'm just here to tell you about the very nearest stars and what's going
on.
But before I do get started with more technical stuff,
I thought I'd show you these travel posters.
This says Kepler one 86 f where the grass is always red or on the other side.
And that put a star system I just showed you.
It's a small red star,
not a big yellow star like our sun.
So you might imagine that if most of the energy output is coming and red
wavelengths,
maybe the vegetation is a different color to harvest light at a different
wavelength.
This one says experienced the gravity of HD four oh three Oh seven g is super
earth and here it's imagining there is a planet called Hg four Oh three Oh seven
g and we know it.
Surface gravity.
We know the mass of the planet and the size and we can calculate the gravity.
It's about one and a half times that of earth.
So,
so imagine you go there and you can parachute,
relax on Kepler 16 be the land of two sons.
We are shadow always has company.
So what I like to say is science fiction got somethings right because you know
there are planets that orbit to stars.
And this would be like this planet tattooing from Star Wars where you'll see two
sunsets and two sons most of the time.
So what we do here in exoplanets.
So to collect our thoughts as we put all the known planets on one plot and hear
what it's showing you is um,
planet size in earth radio.
So this is one earth size where it says earth on this horizontal line,
and this is orbital period in days.
So our earth,
we have 365 days in our year.
So earth would be somewhere over here.
We don't see planets there,
but what I want to press upon you or emphasizes that this is a log log plot.
So it's showing you a vast range of sizes and orbits.
And what this means actually is that wow,
planets come in all sizes,
they actually come in all masses,
all orbits.
It's an incredibly random process of planet formation.
And this was completely not anticipated at all by anybody,
pretty much in all of science.
What astronomers and planetary scientists thought was that our solar system with
earth,
mercury,
Venus,
earth,
Mars,
I'll in the inner part of the solar system and Jupiter,
Saturn,
Uranus,
Neptune,
and maybe Pluto and the outer part of the solar system that was established
dogma that that's helped planetary systems are.
And in fact,
you could have had someone like me,
even though Google wasn't here 20 years ago here in this location,
you could have had,
um,
some like me here 20 years ago,
30 years ago,
if only people had realized that other planetary systems may be very different
from our own on this plot is showing you that some planets,
quite a lot of them,
they have a period of less than one day.
That means their time to get around their star,
their year for one complete orbit is less than a day.
And by Kepler's third law,
it tells us that planets closer to the star are moving faster.
So these planets are also extremely close.
They're so hot.
Our earth here,
we're about 300 Kelvin.
These stars,
these planets are about 2000 Kelvin hot.
Uh,
we have other planets.
We on the other extreme,
they're so far from the star,
um,
their orbital periods like a hundred thousand days.
So it's incredible how vast the system of plant says.
By the way,
can you see each of the colors is a different technique.
I'm not gonna be able to talk about all the ways we can find planets here.
I just wanted to conveyed you the diversity.
But by the way,
can you see by eye what the most common type of planet that we know of today is
you look where like the densest points are.
They're actually here.
See it.
They're all overlapping.
That actually for now the most common type of planet we know of is one between
about one to four times the size of earth.
Actually it's more like two to three times the size of earth.
And we have no solar system counterpart for those.
So we're kind of scratching our heads here cause we don't even totally
understand how the planets in our solar system formed.
And now we have this whole new type of planet that we don't know know what they
are.
So our solar system,
it's hard to find with any current planet finding techniques,
but we still think our solar system is somewhat rare.
It's not that common actually.
Although we don't know how common cause we haven't found any copies yet.
We can say that something like less than 10 less than about 5% of stars like our
sun have a solar system like ours.
And because our son itself is not the most common type of star,
the numbers drop way down.
So now I'm gonna move on to one of the main ways we find planets.
And before I get there,
I just wanted to give you some numbers because when we think about the search
for aliens and the search for life,
we do want to find planets that are somewhat like our own earth and our earth
itself.
It seems so big here,
right?
If you would imagine traveling to Europe or Australia,
it seems super far away.
But in fact our earth is just so tiny when you compare it to any other
astronomical objects like our son for example.
So for our earth it is a hundred times smaller than our sun.
It's also a 100 I think it's,
I think that number might be wrong,
but 100,000 times less massive and 10 billion times fainter than our sun.
So if I was going to ask you,
which technique would you pursue to find another earth?
Would it be one that has to do with size or when that has to do with mass or
when that has to do with brightness?
The size is your best way because it's the best ratio of planet to start.
The problem is that the planet is right next to a big bright,
massive star.
And so all the ways we find planets today,
almost all the ways their ratios,
they're ways of looking at the star and trying to see if a planets there.
So the way we find most planets are found today is with this method called the
transit technique.
Can you see the planet going in front of the star that's supposed to be rough
size compared to a sensai star,
but we don't see that.
We don't spatially resolve stars except for our own Sun.
And so the bottom is showing you what we do find or what we do see rather.
And this kind of idea was,
um,
for planets was actually proposed in the 1950s but look at that.
So what happens is the planet goes in front of the Star and you imagine that
we're taking an image of a star every few seconds or every few minutes and just
looking at that star over and over and over again.
And the starlight drops when the planet goes in front of the star and when the
planet finishes going in front of the star,
then the planet,
the Star returns to its normal brightness and all these little wiggles they have
to do with instrumental noise or the star itself isn't purely constant.
Like our own son has sun spots,
for example.
So believe it or not,
this is how most exoplanets have been found today.
Thousands of them with this technique.
And what happened was we have a special telescope.
How many of you have heard of the Kepler space telescope?
Just things here.
We get a lot of,
you have,
we'll Kepler stared at one part of the sky for four years and it looked at about
150,000 stars and the main problem with Kepler,
why couldn't it actually was looking at a field of millions of stars,
but the problem was data rate.
We can't,
we don't have a way to downlink data.
A lot of it,
and Kepler is orbiting our son just like earth is.
It's in an earth trailing orbit.
So our earth goes around the sun and Kepler's also orbiting the sun and so it's
getting further and further from Earth.
It's hundreds of millions of miles away right now.
And by the way,
just for those people who might still be around and about 60 60 years as cause
Kepler is in a different orbit.
So it's drifting away.
It'll actually return,
but it won't hit us.
So you don't have to worry about that.
Well I thought I'd show you some data and just describe briefly how we do.
People do find planets with Kepler data,
and what it's showing you is relative brightness and the top plot is showing you
what we call raw Kepler data.
And the bottom one is showing you what we call process Kepler data.
So FCC,
the one on the top,
I want you to look at the y axis.
You can see even um,
you know,
looking for small planets involves extremely precise,
photometry precise measurements of brightness of the star.
But what gets in their way,
what gets in our way actually is the fact that we have a lot of noise going on.
Because if you take a detector,
let's say you could open up your phone and shine a laser or an led at the
detector at your camera detector,
and you measured how much comes back at,
you will over one pixel.
That response,
how much light that you're shining on it returns is about,
it can vary by as much as 40%.
And we also have variation between pixels.
So that telescope is not perfectly stable.
If it's moving a little,
then actually we get a different response.
And what we're measuring about the brightness of the star isn't actually the
brightness about the starts.
Really just something that's happening on the detector.
Also,
the temperature control,
the detector really matters.
Now with your phone,
you're not going to notice if you take a picture in the summer or the winter,
but for these um,
very precise measurements that many decimal places,
it actually does really matter.
And so there's a bunch of things going on here,
but sometimes the telescope drifts or it goes into a safe mode.
There's an anomaly that happens and it stops taking data and then when it
returns it's a slightly different temperature or it's moved slightly.
And that's why you're seeing all these different bumps in everything.
And astronomers,
what they do is,
I don't know if those of you who work on any,
you know,
data analysis would find this funny or sad,
but often they don't understand what's happening and why they will do like a
spline fit and just take stuff out.
I always find this astonishing actually.
Ideally you'd like to understand every physical reason about why when your star
is not varying,
the data coming back to you looks crazy.
Like perhaps it's battery cycling and your detector was too close to the battery
is there's a lot of reasons,
but it's true and was really just take it out.
And sometimes I think this prevents finding,
um,
finding planets.
Now on the bottom plot,
you see there's a lot of gaps where the telescope was an observing.
But do you see a planet,
there's a drop in brightness as the planet goes in front of the star and it's
all compressed because here you're seeing relative brightness and at the bottom
you're seeing time,
which is,
it should have said on here days.
So this actually is going from about a hundred to 700 days.
This is 600,
700 days worth of data.
That's incredible.
We have almost no experiments in astronomy that do this.
You can see that,
you can see where it is because there's an arrow pointing to it.
And by the way,
um,
the way we do find planets is use a simple algorithm is really just like a box
fitting method.
Imagine you just have a box and you take all your data and you run through
different possible periods and you phase hold your data on that period.
And then you literally are just looking for a box.
I mean there's other ways to do it,
but that one proved the most reliable and the most efficient.
Now one funny thing about the that happened earlier on was the Kepler team,
they just cut their period off at three days.
So you know,
you're choosing your algorithm and your boundaries three days to let's say 300
days and they didn't find any of those one day period planets that because their
algorithm,
you know,
we always say about computers is it'll do what you tell it to do,
that it won't do what you're not telling it.
So you really want to make sure that you can see all things.
So if you take this data and faithful debt and just show it around the transit
itself,
there it is.
Now there's time and hours and there's relative brightness.
And I just want you to look at that measure precision for a second.
Oh 0.9 900 905 and remember I told you that Earth is a hundred times smaller
than our sun,
but we're measuring area here cause it's the drop and brightness as the planet
blocks out the star light.
So that will be about a part in 10,000 to find an earth sized planet.
It's amazing.
We,
if I'd ask you,
do any of you at any time in your life had you ever made a measurement to four
decimal places?
Um,
unless it's the gravitational wave people,
most people have not done the sentence.
So it's incredible breathtaking telescope in space and there's just tons and
tons of great data on it.
I just wanted you to know that different planets have different transits,
their transit light curve looks different and there's a huge amount of
information buried in the light curve.
And so people are busy working away to try to understand what if the planets on
an eccentric orbit,
if the planet might have moons,
some of these planets are massive and close to the star and they literally are
totally distorting the star.
You can see that in the light curve.
And so there's a lot of stuff going on.
And finally,
as part of this introduction,
I wanted to show you this plot,
this bar chart so that you could have a little more quantitative,
um,
just to empathy so that you can walk away with one of the main points I wanted
to convey to you that the most common type of planet we know of,
it's not a big planet like Jupiter.
It's actually these planets about twice the size of earth,
which we have no solar system counterparts.
This is showing you the fraction of stars with planets
and it's showing you a bar chart of planet size,
uh,
plant size relative to Earth.
So down on the right you're seeing planets that are the size of Jupiter.
Jupiter is about 11 times the size of earth and you're seeing planets that are
between one to three times the size of earth that are literally 10 times more
common than Jupiter sized planets.
Now,
if you don't pay attention to planetary science,
this just might be like,
okay,
here's a cool factoid,
but I want to emphasize one more time that an egg in planetary science,
people assume that Jupiter was the natural end product,
that when a planet starts forming,
it eventually gets big enough by rocks and Isis colliding together.
But essentially it acts like a cosmic vacuum cleaner.
It sucks up all the,
all the gas around it,
and I just finished his growing when there's no more material to create.
It's like Luis,
we used to have the joke that's,
I don't know if you find it funny here,
it's like Google,
you know,
Google started and grew and grew and grew and really dominated.
Nothing else could conform as we saw Jupiter.
So the fact that all these other planetary systems not only don't have a
Jupiter,
but they have these smaller planets.
What happened?
The black instead of Google,
you have a hundred different companies all kind of like Google.
So it's not what we expected.
So to summarize that intro,
exoplanets are diverse,
covering nearly all masses sizes and orbits possible and these small planets are
incredibly common.
So now I'm going to move on to the so called habitable zone.
It's a kind of catch phrase that means like the goldilocks zone.
When we search for planets,
we want to find small planets that have a solid surface that might be able to
host life.
And we want planet.
So the right temperature,
not too hot,
not too cold,
but just right for life.
So I think some of you said when I said have you heard of the Trappist planets?
And it will.
Some people said yes you have.
Well I'm going to show you what's behind those sales.
So instead of like the newspaper article,
just hyping it all,
this is actually the trappist planet discovery and maybe now you have a bit more
tools to to understand what it is it's showing you days just normalized I guess
at one day one to 23 and this is looking at the star Trappist one as a function
of time.
And this was taken by,
not Kepler,
but the Spitzer space telescope and infrared telescope that's about 80
centimeters in diameter and it's also a in an earth trailing heliocentric orbit.
And again it has gaps when the telescope was in observing or when it down linked
to earth.
And can you see the transits,
they're all labeled for you.
But look at all these drops and brightness.
This is incredible.
They're all these different drops and they're all different sizes.
And some of them,
if you see two letters,
the trans,
that was a double transits,
two planets were transiting the star at the same time.
So this is really interesting and I also want to draw your attention to the
scale here.
Remember the last one?
It was like four decimal places.
This one drop.
And brightness here is only about a percent.
And this system I wanted to tell you about because we're the field now is doing
what's easy,
not what we necessarily wanted to do.
We're just doing the easiest thing to do.
And the particular group who found this,
um,
they want purposely after the very smallest stars in existence and this cartoon
here now,
now there's a few things going on here,
but on the left you can browse the face folded data for each planet separated on
its own.
And you can see there are seven planets and they're going from close to the star
to further from the star where the further the planet is from the star,
the slower it travels around the star on,
the longer the transit is on the hole.
And on the right it's showing you just some schematics.
This yellow thing here would be our son.
You could draw like a giant,
giant circle.
And this is Jupiter and this is the star Trappist one.
It's so small,
almost the size of Jupiter.
If it were any smaller or colder,
it wouldn't be a star.
It wouldn't be able to fuse hydrogen in the core.
So remember the planets going in front of the star and blocking light,
a smaller starts just easier to find planets around.
So there's a lot of uh,
their skill and luck involved in exoplanets,
just like any field.
But it was incredible because the team had a pilot program to look at 20 stars
and one of those 20 had this incredible planetary system.
And here it's showing you that in our son we have our inner planets,
mercury,
Venus,
Earth,
Mars,
Jupiter has some moons.
And Wow,
this one has all these planets.
And what's so great about it is that,
um,
there may be a chance that one of them has the right amount of energy hitting it
from the star and could be really the right temperature for life.
So one of the things I do is I make very complicated computer models to work
through all of this based on the atmosphere and the greenhouse gasses and things
like that.
But instead of telling you that,
I will let me take you on a virtual trip to one of these planets.
And it's not just the Trappist one star,
but there are lots of small stars out there and way more astronomers just
observing small stars for planets.
So let's imagine for a moment we could transport ourselves to one of these,
not the Trappist ones,
but some planets orbiting a slightly bigger star.
And the first thing you notice is a possibility that that star would be very big
on the sky.
And the artists here has made it a take the artist's license to make the sky a
different color and to show you other planets in that same system.
Well,
one of the things about these planets,
they're so close to the star that there what were called tidally locked,
just like the moon shows the same face to Earth at all times.
These planets,
um,
should have interacted with their star,
with tides.
So that one day,
one rotation is the same as one year,
one revolution.
And that's what our moon does.
If you've,
you know,
the moon,
you only see the same face at all time because the moon,
it's only rotating one time for every time it orbits.
And we think the same.
Should be of these planets.
So what that means if we could go to that planet is that the sun,
that star,
the sun would be in the same place of the sky at all times.
Yeah.
So you can choose to go where it's always sunny.
The surround horse could go where it's always night.
And if anything too is because the small stars have very low energy output.
So the planet has to be very close to the star to receive the right amount of
energy.
And so it's orbiting the star with short periods.
Like these Trappist planets have period on the order of one day to like 10 days.
So that's um,
your birthday would be every 10 days.
Um,
so this planet would be interesting for that reason alone,
but in fact,
if you think more carefully about this planet,
it wouldn't be great to visit because these [inaudible] stars have flares.
They're giving off flares.
Does anyone remember?
I don't know if annual,
remember her read about this,
like in the 19,
don't see like the late 1980s,
our son had a giant flare and it knocked out candidates power in Quebec.
And this is something astronomers actually worry about to or not just
astronomers,
that these big burst of energy could come and like literally destroy our power.
Well on this particular planet that would be happening on a daily basis in much
bigger amounts than,
than what we've seen here.
So if you're on that,
if you visited and you don't,
you could get cancer literally just from all these high energy particles
whizzing by.
You flip out your phone,
the electronics will get knocked off.
So maybe it's not such a great planet to visit after all,
but I was just trying to convey to you that these small stars that are 10 to 50%
the size of our sun,
they're the ones that are being scoured for habitable planets now.
But will we be able to recognize these planets are life on them.
They're so different from our sun and what we're used to here.
We're not really sure.
And I just listed three for those who would read the news or notice that last
summer there was one announced around Proxima Centauri B.
That's our very nearest star to our son.
And the trap is planets.
There was another one mentioned more recently,
so that's where we're at.
And the habitable zone estimate is actually from very simple energy but energy
budgets.
So I do have one more topic.
I have a couple more topics,
but the next sort of more meaty topic would be is on an exoplanet atmospheres.
Because the one thing about these so called habitable worlds,
we have no idea what they're like.
We know that there,
um,
size and their mass,
but that's it.
That's why they're colored white hair.
We don't know.
Like in our own earth,
people are worried about parts per million of carbon dioxide,
right?
Remember,
our earth has had a mean of 40 million,
40 parts per million,
400 parts per million carbon dioxide.
And before we started out with decades ago,
like three 50.
Now imagine on another planet,
we're not just thinking of 50 part per million,
more carbon dioxide,
but maybe double or triple or we have other greenhouse gases.
So we need to understand the atmosphere before we can understand whether the
planet's surface could be good enough for life or whether it's too hot or too
cold.
So the next thing been talking about is atmospheres.
But before I do that,
actually I forgot to show you one thing on here.
Did you look at this data?
Can you see a flare?
Okay,
look at this is what it looks like.
The star brightened suddenly and actually happened.
You know,
every few days on this starts getting a flare,
which maybe is not too bad,
right?
If you have ginormous circuit breakers on all your power grid,
but other stars like Proxima Centauri B,
it's flaring like dozens of times a day basically.
So these m stars,
they're just very badly behaved.
They're very active,
just not,
not great.
But I wanted you to see that in the data.
That's a tiny,
tiny flare there.
But at visible wavelengths and ultraviolet,
it would have much more energy compared to the infrared wavelengths where it's
being measured.
So I didn't want to just,
I just have a few slides on this right now,
but I remember when we were talking about the planet going in front of the star,
I wanted to convey to you the main way that we study exoplanet atmospheres today
and what's showing you on the left is a cartoon showing you a planet going in
front of the star with the atmosphere
highlighted.
I'm exaggerated,
but the concept is that when the planet goes in front of the star,
some of the star light shines through the atmosphere.
And believe it or not,
we can pick up planet atmosphere signals in that light coming through.
And we think about it for a minute.
We'll observe the star on its own and then the star during transit and
essentially subtract.
It's kind of hard cause we're subtracting two big numbers and um,
just all modesty aside for a moment,
I invented this technique and when I worked on this,
at the time that I started,
honestly,
I don't know,
I wasn't really thinking like in research,
if you're lucky,
you can kind of do whatever you want.
That doesn't happen as you get older and have a real job.
But um,
I was just working on this and people honestly,
um,
didn't understand why people worked on exoplanets because we didn't have that
plot like full of so many,
you can barely count them.
They're like maybe two or three or four new planets and they were all in very
short periods and because everybody thought we had our solar system,
no one even believed they were planets and just sort of by kind of good fortune
or just risk taking.
I decided to work on exoplanets when I was at Harvard as a graduate student and
my advisor gave me this problem.
He said,
why don't you work on atmospheres of these planets?
Because we know a lot about binary stars.
There's stars that orbit each other.
So just kind of take that.
And he gave me a code in Fortran and like I couldn't use it and he's that good.
It was really funny because the code was so old that they had to use a variable
name that had to be reused over and over because they couldn't store a lot of
stuff.
And just,
it was funny the way it was done.
And in stars,
there's a lot of free electrons,
so you use free electrons as it six variable.
But planet atmospheres have molecules.
There's no free electrons cause it's colder.
So in the end I had to throw it out a day,
decided to program in c and later now I adopted python,
which feels a bit lazy to be honest.
But everybody is doing that and there's a lot of packages and stuff.
So I worked on the atmospheres and then when I finished graduate school,
we didn't have any transiting planets.
But the chance to transit,
um,
depends on how close the planet is to the star.
Just like showing it,
throwing darts.
It's not a perfect analogy,
but if you're really close to the screen,
it's really easy to hit it.
If you're further away,
your angle gets such that it's harder.
So when I started my postdoc,
um,
everyone kept asking him,
what's the next big thing?
What's the next big thing?
You know,
if you don't know anything,
those of us who struggle with small talk,
if you don't know,
have a question.
That's the thing.
You can ask someone.
What's the next Big Bang?
So looking back,
you see Paul all had problems,
the small talk.
And so I'd say,
you know,
transits,
we have no transiting planets,
but it's going to happen,
right?
If the chance to transit for a planet in a four day orbit is about 10% and we
have seven of these now,
like we're not going to get to 10 and get a transit,
but it's going to happen.
It's more and more chance the more we find.
So I worked really hard to,
this is the thing I've worked on when I got out of Grad school and there it was.
And a couple of years later the observers use Hubble space telescope and use
what I said they should look for and they found it.
And you think that would be great and that after that life would be great.
But people didn't think this would ever go anywhere.
They're thinking,
well,
it's a one object.
When methods success,
it's so hard.
Even I saw a few of you smile when I say,
you know,
we,
this atmosphere,
it's so tiny.
And now we want to subtract two big numbers and see the features and no one
thought it would ever go anywhere.
But now it's actually one of the biggest fields.
It's so big and crowded that I barely work on this part now.
So out of all of that,
I'm going to,
I picked one to show you because our data's really horrible actually.
So I just picked one to show you.
I kind of cherry pick the best one,
but I want to make sure that you understand the concept and walk away with it
because it could happen in the summer or next year or five years.
Someone might say,
Oh,
I think I found a sign of life.
And so I was just trying to prepare you to know what that is.
So what I want you to think about promoting is this atmosphere.
And I want you to imagine that if the atmosphere is absorbing strongly,
the planet looks a tiny bit bigger,
then if the planet had no atmosphere,
we're at a wavelength where the planet was not absorbing it all.
Okay?
So think about our earth here.
Like when on a clear day or clear night you can see the sky.
So that's like a transparent wavelength.
There's nothing happening there.
But if you actually could look in the infrared,
we can't see the sky in the infrared for most of the infrared cause we have
carbon dioxide and other gasses absorbing and strongly.
So the question,
so how we try to think of this problem is we think that the planet looks bigger
at a wavelength door.
It's absorbing and smaller at a wavelength where it's more transparent.
And so here's the data that I chose to show you.
And what you see here is the transit depth.
So this is trying to tell you how big the planet is,
um,
and the wavelength than microns showing you.
Um,
we've lengthened microns.
Visible wavelengths is about 0.2,
2.8 microns.
And then the near infrared is further.
Now what you're supposed to see here is look at the black points,
which are real data taken with the Hubble Space Telescope,
with their aerobars.
And what you're supposed to do is agree or evaluate for yourself whether or not
this is different from a straight line.
If this was a straight line,
we'd say the planet is not changing size with wavelength and it's no longer,
it's not more transparent or less,
more absorbing wavelength with respect to each other and what the red points
are.
Red,
I mean the model,
the curves are models they're generated with computer codes that take libraries
of mullet molecular data ultimately generated from quantum mechanics and putting
it through like an atmosphere model.
And what these,
this,
these big bumps shown by the model or their water vapor,
water vapor is even on earth.
Our strongest greenhouse gas,
it's extremely strongly absorbing and that big bump your seam around 1.4 microns
there.
That's from water vapor.
So the model fit,
the quantum mechanics tells us water is strongly absorbing there.
We see that our spectrum changes there and Voila,
we call this a detection of water vapor in an exoplanet atmosphere.
Now you see it,
the shorter wavelengths,
Adidas is not as good.
It's just not really telling us much.
Um,
and this is kind of what we see and this is the best data that we have.
I have another,
I did choose one more plot to show you.
Um,
usually when I show this,
the audience laughs,
but this is the same kind of data and it's showing you the absorption and
percent.
So think of that like the planet size and the blue points,
our data taken with the Hubble Space Telescope and you're supposed to see if you
know it's different from a straight line or not.
Um,
the one at the bottom not right,
that's just noise or there's,
it's not different from a straight line.
The one on top is,
and the one in the middle is definitely as well.
So that's where we're at for exoplanet atmospheres.
And,
but just to leave you with one more detail that most of these exoplanets people
are spending a lot of Hubble space telescope time and a lot of models working
really hard.
We're sort of stuck with what we have.
The Hubble Space Telescope is a shared observation observatory and as
instruments that were designed for things not related to exoplanets.
And we can really only look at this very narrow part in the spectrum.
And most,
um,
most of these exoplanet atmospheres really,
we do just see a straight line and people invoke clouds.
I want you to imagine for a minute you're on a plane.
And you know how when you go through the clouds,
you can't see anything looking down.
It's all that lower atmosphere is blocked.
But that lower atmosphere is what were all the spectral lines are forming.
So we think that what's happening is that the starlight is going through the
atmosphere,
but actually it's not sitting in a cloud and not making it through.
So to finish up this part about atmospheres,
what we want to do in the future with new telescopes is look at atmospheres of
small planets.
And we want to look for signs of water vapor on small,
rocky worlds.
And we want to look for signs of gases that don't belong that might be
attributed to life.
Now on our own planet,
all of us humans,
we require oxygen to breathe that I think everybody knows.
But what people forget is that our atmosphere is composed of 20% by volume
oxygen.
But without life,
without plants and photosynthetic bacteria,
we would actually have no oxygen in our atmosphere
as this is amazing to think about that.
When I think about aliens,
I like to think that there are intelligent aliens around some of those planets
orbiting nearby stars and that they're building the kind of telescopes I'm about
to tell you about.
And they look at our planet and they see all this oxygen and they know that
oxygen is a highly reactive gas and that it shouldn't be there.
And I really hope they're out there,
you know,
scratching their heads,
trying to weigh in on whether or not this means there is life on earth.
So that's our,
that's overly simplified.
But that actually honestly is where people had been thinking for a long,
long time.
And we're trying to do something different now.
Look at different molecules.
And I have this illustration here showing you a sea of molecules that fills
chemical space.
And that if we can work through all these molecules and think about which ones
you know might have life on them,
it might might be a signature of life.
It might increase our chances of being able to find an identify life on some of
the planets that were just struggling to observe.
So this field is kind of in the future.
But that's in a nutshell what this sort of very next milestone in exoplanets
says.
It's setting small planet atmospheres,
looking for signs of life on them.
So to summarize that part,
um,
dozens of exoplanet atmospheres have been observed with tiny signals on order to
parts per thousand and oxygen.
And a small planet atmosphere means our favorite way to find signs of life on
another world.
But because it's upcoming,
people are generating all sorts of false positive scenarios.
How could oxygen be generated without it actually being from life?
So this is a TBD stayed tuned kind of topic.
Now for the last part of my talk,
I will actually just tell you a bit about the telescopes that we're going to use
to study these planets.
This one is the James Webb space telescope.
Initially it was considered like the follow on humble,
but it's actually quite different.
It's far bigger.
It's going to orbit a million and a half miles from earth and it's going to work
in the infrared and look how it's um,
on the left as the artist's conception,
which shows you the mirror as well as this very large tennis court size solar
shield in each of those layers has a different weave woven pattern.
So when energy gets absorbed it will be readmitted in a way that doesn't keep
getting absorbed and readmitted and hitting the telescope and heating it up.
Remember when I told you before about temperature control of the detector will
in this case,
um,
the whole telescope has to operate very,
very cold because it's working at infrared wavelengths where heat from the
instruments and the sun would just destroy observations on the right.
That's actually a real image,
real photograph,
real image taken at Goddard Space Flight Center on April 24th,
2017 and there you see all those mirror segments were actually put into place
over the last nine months or so.
Now it has to be shipped to Johnson space flight center.
It actually just arrived.
I got an email like yesterday,
but you know what,
it had to be driven and it was actually put on a plane and flown to Texas and
landed and then put it on another vehicle.
And these vehicles are big and they have to drive like they have to drive
through first just to make sure there's clearance and all the roads.
But I dunno,
I don't know how much they tell the pilot of this ultimately $8 billion
telescope of what it's actually they're flying and landing.
Um,
I don't know about that.
So what we're going to do is use the James Webb space telescope to look at
atmospheres in the way I described and were people are busy trying to find
planets like the Trappist planets and other planets to follow up and over at
Mit.
We have,
uh,
MIT led NASA mission that we're working on.
It's supposed to launch in March,
2018 and the goal of this space telescope is to find planets,
find more transiting planets.
So we'll have that pool of planets orbiting,
um,
small stars whose atmospheres we can follow up.
And I want to make sure I leave time for questions.
So I'm just going to speed through some photos.
Here's our kind of cardboard model just to show you how big it is.
The whole space telescope,
the whole,
um,
I guess spacecraft bus,
it's not really that big actually.
And inside of it are these four identical cameras.
They're essentially glorified telephoto lenses that are very specially made to
not have any vignetting and that temperature doesn't affect them very much.
Um,
we put our smallest guy with the camera,
so it looks as big as it can.
It's,
um,
aperture is really only about 10 centimeters.
It has a giant baffle to block out like stray light from the moon or from Venus
or other planets.
And at the bottom there's a Lincoln lab,
Mit Lincoln lab made CCD detector.
Um,
I had some numbers.
If you're interested in them,
I can share them with you.
But here's some real recent pictures and this is showing you down in Virginia at
a place called orbital STK.
They're the ones making the spacecraft.
Boston.
Here you see a solar panel that's been mounted.
It's our only deployable and here's an antenna that's going to send data down to
earth.
Over here you see one of the cameras being tested and if it's not being,
it's the vacuum chamber is open,
but it's putting in a vacuum chamber to simulate space and it thermal cycles and
later on gets vibration tested to show that it will perform as we expect you to
space.
Because of course you have to build at room temperature.
But in space this camera will be operating at a much colder temperature.
Now,
um,
in this particular telescope,
what's cool about it is it's going to observe a very big part of the sky.
Um,
I did just have some simulated data to show you.
Here's showing you one square degree,
a small patch of the sky.
Like if you put your thumb up like that,
that's about one degree.
And here's one of the CCD cameras that's actually 12 by 12.
So that little one degree patches here and now 12 degrees is more like if you
stretched your hand.
But each camera will actually have foresee cds.
So now we're here 24 degrees by 24 degrees
field of view from one test cam.
Remember there are four cameras and for those who knows something about
astronomy,
there would be a Ryan.
So now look how many stars were looking at.
So we have a,
I wish we had a big huge data problem on our hands.
We don't though,
because we can't downlink all the data all the time.
We take images,
but we have to stack them on board so we can downlink the data through the deep
space network,
that big radio dishes that received data from NASA missions.
Each of these cameras now would be one square.
So Ryan would fit in one of these squares and it would line up like this and
we'll look at each patch of the sky and we will actually,
um,
tile it.
Looking at the southern hemisphere in the first year in the northern hemisphere
in the second year.
So that's kind of where we're at.
We have this commission there.
And for the very last part of my talk,
I just wanted to give you a glimpse of the future because in exoplanets,
each ideas crazier than the last 10.
So these trends,
that's our only the first part of a very long story,
right?
It requires,
um,
fortuitous alignment.
The planets or orbit has to be lined up.
So the planet is going in front of the Star as seemed from your telescope.
But we're thinking as hard as we can tell from theory and observation,
all stars have different alignments.
They're born out of the spherical cloud and they collapse to a desk.
So whether they clap this way or this way or this way,
and the planet's,
most of them are in their equity Loreal plane,
but not all of them.
And so,
yeah,
I mean,
they're not all going to be doing that.
And so we'd really like to be able to study the very nearest stars whose planets
probably aren't translating for our earth.
It's probability to transit would only be one in 200.
So you'd have to look at 200 stars of all of them had an earth,
you'd see a transiting earth.
So this new one,
this new method I want to end with,
we call it star shade.
It's a giant,
especially shape screen here.
It's showing you that it could launch together with a telescope and it would
have these giant pedals unfurl from a stowed position.
And here you see this thing would be tens of meters in diameter and it would
actually have to fly from the telescope tens of thousands of kilometers and
literally line up perfectly to,
um,
block out the star light so we can see the planets directly.
Um,
and this idea actually came about in the 1960s by someone named Lyman Spitzer
and through this weird,
like six degrees of separation thing.
My new neighbor is related to him.
It was his sister's granddaughter.
And yeah,
it's every decade or so this idea has been revisited because it wasn't feasible
in any way before.
In fact what you,
um,
you can ask me in Q and a if you want to know why it's that shape and
everything.
Cause I will run out of time to explain the details to you.
But here's one of the pedals that would be about seven meters long and it has
this very long shape here.
Hope they'll bring it back cause I have some more really cool pictures.
And here's the star shade lab at NASA's Jet Propulsion Laboratory in Pasadena,
California,
where you see they have smaller scale versions.
They're working on what you call membrane management,
how you can fold this thing up and deployed on.
So,
and you can see they've been working on it a long time with a lot of different
models.
Okay,
I'm going to end my talk with more of this software.
I took another movie clip showing you our earth and all the stars with no
planets around it.
And this is going to start to zoom away from Earth.
I wanted you to,
you know,
to leave you with that thought that they're just so many stars out there,
uh,
with planets.
Um,
we think we know of thousands of stars with planets now,
but honestly,
our galaxy has hundreds of millions,
hundreds of billions of stars,
and it's only the really nearby ones nearest to earth who that we can study
who's atmospheres we can see and who we can really study in detail to find out
whether there are signs of life on other worlds.
And in case any of you wanted to know which part of our galaxy have we observed
so far,
really only the tiniest parts surrounding our own earth and some techniques.
Let us go a little further away.
Okay.
So to summarize,
um,
thousands of planets are known to orbit nearby stars.
Most of this information is limited sizes and Orbitz and some masses.
These earth sized planets in the so called habitable zones of small stars are
being detected like the Trappist ones that I dwelled upon.
And then I gave you a little taste about how most of our exciting,
um,
observations remain in the future.
Thank you for your attention.
[inaudible]
okay,
we have time for questions.
Thank you for the talk.
That was great.
Um,
my question is about whether you're able to infer the eccentricity of the orbits
of these exoplanets.
Because it strikes me that if you have a highly elliptical orbit that's far less
likely to support life than something that's close to circular.
Yes,
we can detect eccentricities.
It's very hard to do with method I showed you because eccentric planets,
you know,
they'll go slowly and then when their closest sir and they go quickly and people
try to find it based on the
duration of the transit if it's asymmetric.
But there is another method called rate of seat or the method and there are the
planets are orbiting the common center of mass and we can measure actually the
stars line of sight motion.
And that technique does let you determine the centricity of it.
But you know what?
It's a good question because we don't have all information for all stars.
Not all stars can we make all those observations for it.
So it's possible that we find another planet and we don't know what sex
centricity.
And so we may not know all the things we want to know to be able to put all the
puzzle pieces together.
But that said,
people will always try to find a way to make it happen.
So not necessarily measure,
but that's fine.
It can be eccentric and it can still have the right temperature.
Our Ocean,
as you know,
cause we live in Boston,
right?
You know how summer happens.
Well before we get the hottest part of the summer,
right?
Because our ocean is a giant he capacitor.
So there's a lot of arguments people can make qualitatively and quantitatively
about why we're not too worried about eccentricity.
Thank you.
So two questions might be naive,
but what are those?
For a long time,
if you watched earth for the longest time,
you wouldn't see any oxygen cause there wasn't any.
Right.
It's only relatively,
you know,
say the recent half of the history of the planet,
there's oxygen.
Can you detect the kinds of atmospheres you might have in the early part of
this?
Good question.
No,
it's a great question and I'm glad you asked it because I had to gloss over.
I glossed over a lot of things.
Yes,
we've only had oxygen prominent in our atmosphere for about half of our history.
And you know what,
there's some chance we never would have had it at all because there's the
thought that some kind of life makes oxygen,
other life uses it and maybe it should be closer to zero,
right?
Zero leftover people.
Do we do everything we can or through time?
What did it look like?
So we could have seen our earth,
we could have identified its atmosphere with the giant water vapor features,
but we might not be able to see signs of life.
Some people think our early earth was covered with antigens,
methane producing bacteria.
Other people have found that,
you know what,
ozone is a nonlinear indicator of oxygen.
You can have a tiny amount of oxygen and like quite a lot of ozone.
So we're doing the best we can.
Um,
in the ideal world,
we'd just look at the whole spectrum.
And then gay,
we'd have tons of data,
but not sure.
So what you're trying to,
what you're not trying to say.
But what I'll use that to communicate is that we could apply this where we just
won't see signs of life even though it's there.
Another quick question,
just so we have interesting ecosystems that are evolving the bottom of the ocean
where you've got,
she'd coming up from the core.
Do we know anything about the course of these planets anyway?
Hey Mike,
try to figure that out.
Okay.
Do we know anything about the course of these planets?
I'm not really actually,
but we do still try to think about it and make models and consider all the
possibilities.
Um,
but it's a little aside to what you're saying.
you know,
people do think about this.
We try to understand the chorus.
We've motivated high pressure physics experiments with these giant gas guns and
giant other shock experiments that usually they use for,
believe it or not,
arms control.
They usually use it for nuclear studies.
So we are actually trying to understand what might be on the inside,
but it doesn't lend its way to a lot of observables.
Yes.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
It's super interesting topic.
I'll never look at that.
Uh,
at your office building
the same as I walk around Cambridge knowing what type of research is happening
there.
Um,
so I,
I love the concept of preparing us for this finding.
Um,
I think that that's really exciting and it almost feels,
you know,
the way that you presented as being a inevitable,
I hope,
what type of chain reaction would happen in the scientific community,
um,
really throughout our kind of earth,
uh,
when life is discovered.
Well,
I think that question is a tough one and I think most people here would have
their own answer that's different.
But the best way that I see it happening is first of all,
some kind of overhype like if you will Google,
you can Google that,
you know,
the Trappist one discovery and see what it described.
And NASA,
I was part of the presentation is like the independent commentator,
they did a good job and they made it clear why it was exciting,
why we're excited about it.
But sort of if you read all the news articles,
there's a bit of broken telephone going on,
right?
So I think that would happen.
We see oxygen,
Yay,
this is great.
We found life.
The aliens are coming,
but actually really it will take much longer.
This is going to take at least a generation,
maybe two or even three.
And I like to think back to the whole,
um,
the compare to can revolution,
right?
People thought that our earth was the center of the universe and that
everything,
the sun,
the stars,
the planets,
everything revolved around earth.
But comparing because put forth,
no,
actually our son should be the center of the universe.
Everything's relevant around the sun.
And it took like 400 years before people finally just accepted that as just
general knowledge because Newton had to come and make Newtonian mechanics and
then Haley came and predicted Haley's comment would return after 75 years.
And I'm not a historian or anything,
but so probably people kind of all believed it eventually.
But when Halley's comet returned 75 years later,
okay,
there it's a slam dunk.
Our son,
everything's orbiting the sun.
So I'm not sure what it will be like.
Actually,
I'm not sure if the data will be believable.
If we can rule out every scenario that is not a false positive.
So my best guess is we'll find it and there'll be some overhype then that will
die down and then future generations of telescopes will do a better job and
ruling it in her out.
And I hope we'll find eventually lots of planets will receive these signs and we
can put it all together.
Thank you.
It's not like the movie
arrival.
How many of dealing with hearsay rival?
I liked to ride,
I didn't like movies so much itself but I love the concept of the aliens came
and they were so different from anything we could imagine.
So it's not going to be obvious like that.
Hello.
Um,
I have a question.
You were talking about the amount of data that you collect versus what you can
ship down.
Can you give us an idea of what that ratio is and is there any possibility to do
processing on the satellite?
The three centers?
That one first because that gives us like,
we never want a process on the satellite cause we love looking at all the data.
And remember when I showed you all those,
it's going up.
It's going down.
Like we love to know what's happened with all of the stars and all the areas of
the data.
So let's see.
Um,
okay
with tests,
we're going to be orbiting this highly elliptical orbit and we're going to zoom
by earth for a few days and we can download it at a rate of almost like a
hundred megabytes per second.
But Kepler being that you know,
millions of my hundreds million miles away,
it's a lot less,
I want to say I know exactly what it like.
Okay.
A hundred or a thousand kilobits per second.
So we're just so limited right in the power we have to transmit the data and
receive it.
So we're always trying to do that better.
Now in terms of total data,
I want to say all of the Kepler data,
cause they're not sending down all the images they're sending down postage
stamps.
It might be like on the order of a terabyte.
So really it's not collecting the data and storing it.
Sometimes people come up with ways they want to analyze it.
Like,
how do you get rid of variable stars,
star spots?
They want to use something they call Gaussian processes,
which is extremely computationally intensive.
So we dropped that and do something simpler.
I don't know if that answers your question but at least it gives you some more
numbers.
All right.
Thank you.
Are there,
uh,
thank you again for the talk.
Uh,
if people want to get involved,
there's a,
a,
a a citizen science project called project Panoply's that I'm involved with
where uh,
some folks at a k at the Keck telescope and Subaru in Hawaii are organizing this
effort for people to make robotic telescopes that it'll do it ground based
survey.
Nowhere nears deepest tests,
but uh,
to find candidates for further investigation.
Yeah,
I should have mentioned that.
There's so many ways to get involved if you want to,
if you want to get involved with test data and lend some brainpower or
algorithms or something else,
let me know.
Just look me up on the internet and send me an email.
You can do this other one is amazing,
but Olivia Guianan,
I'm an astronomer in his free time.
He's put together a relatively low cost system.
I want to say it's like $1,000 or something.
5,000 oh my gosh.
It's a little higher than I thought it was going to be.
So you,
yourself or your,
you know,
children's school or your astronomy club,
you can actually get one of these and put it anywhere in your backyard or sent
it to Hawaii and he's going to make this website where you can decide what you
want to observe or he'll decide for you and you send amazing job with software.
Usually we do aperture photometry,
we plunk a circle around our object,
but because of the blurring effects of earth's atmosphere and instruments,
especially widefield ones,
that's not really cool.
So he's developed a brand new way to do this and do with software processing way
better.
And he wants,
yeah,
it's a great thing.
I wanted to do this as well,
and if I have enough time,
finally,
if you wanted to do the,
honestly,
I'm not even making this up.
I know you're all at Google and everything,
but the easiest way to get involved as crowdsourcing through planet hunters.org
and you can literally just look through light curves and help crowdsourcing
fashion identify drops in the light curve that are due to a planet.
That's probably the easiest way but probably not as sophisticated as most of you
can handle.
Oh,
hi.
I have a kind of nit picky uh,
data analysis question,
so I apologize for that.
When you were describing,
um,
the,
how you actually go from the raw data to the process data,
it seems to me like naively I would guess the best method to do that would be to
pick a calibration star and just subtract that from it or something or some
average like that as opposed to what you described,
which was kind of sounded like making it up.
Well,
people do a lot of different things and I certainly did skip a lot of steps.
There is a calibration processing that goes on based on people know about the
instrument itself.
And that happens before usually people like me and other strong receipt.
But I know what you're saying is that traditionally what we would do is we take
an average of all non variant SARS that are behaving well and then we just sort
of subtract out.
But the thing is the detector is so big here and things happening on one part of
the detector are not necessarily exactly what's happening on the other part of
the dinner,
the detector.
So that sort of averaging isn't typically used in this regard.
But it is a good question and there are lots of ways people are doing it and I
certainly didn't do it justice.
Can I go again?
Sure.
Yeah.
We have 36 seconds.
Okay.
Uh,
the one that you were talking about at the very end with the shade that would
block the starshade?
Yeah,
that seems like it would only work in really specific circumstances.
Like you could set it up to look at one star.
Yes,
that's it.
Star shade itself.
The star shade has a spacecraft attached to it and it has a lineup with the
telescope and so it actually has to move across the sky for each one.
And so when you think about star shade and what it can do,
it has a certain number of retargets so it can move around a certain number of
times,
which may be on the order of a hundred or 300 times.
And so you need to choose wisely how you're going to move across the sky and
which targets you're going to look at.
Yes.
Okay.
Well,
we're out of time and I just want to thank you for coming to my talk.
Okay.